pour certains c'est la fuite en bravant
le risque d'une chute pour échapper aux
forces de l'ordre plutôt bien organisé
ces manifestants quittent ensuite en
enfourchant des motos d'autres par
contre ont baissé les bras et se sont
rendus à la police anglaise mais le
combat est loin d'être terminé
la mobilisation en cours depuis plus de
cinq mois à hong kong et sans précédent
il est entré la semaine dernière dans
une phase plus radicale et plus violents
c'est ici dans l'école polytechnique de
la métropole que s'est retranché le
noyau dur de la contestation
l'établissement qui était la proie des
flammes
il y à quelques ares est devenue le
symbole de la résistance contre les
autorités chinoises alors que la police
profitent d'un répit pour défaire les
barricades érigées par les
contestataires
elle prévient que sa patience a des
limites à votre droite ne testez
panneaux lumineux avertit le commandant
régional du quartier kahoul ou non les
images du soulèvement qui font le tour
du monde
exaspère les autorités de pékin ce qui
alimente la crainte d'une intervention
chinoise mais rien pour décourager les
irréductibles qui disent être prêts à
aller jusqu'au bout
on ne se laissera pas faire dit elle
mais l'épuisement commence à s'installer
je n'ai pas dormi depuis trois jours
clame celui ci
la fatigue extrême des derniers jours
semble en tout cas porté un coup dur au
moral de certains des protagonistes du
mouvement fatah celui ci a peur que si
le mouvement percée de bataille à la
polytechnique la révolution serait
terminée en attendant des membres des
ong tentent de faire le lien entre la
police et les protestataires
pour l'instant ce juriste dit avoir
obtenu l'assurance que la police les
laissera quitter les lieux de façon
pacifique et qu'il n'y aura pas de
violences
la mobilisation tiendra-t-elle le coup
encore longtemps
tout dépendra des ressources des
manifestants et surtout de ce que fera
le gouvernement chinois ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal